لسنوات كانت المملكه المتحده واحده من
اكثر الدول التي لديها درايه كبيره بطبيعه
التحالفات والنزاعات في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هذا الدور تقلص كثيرا خلال السنوات
الماضيه لكن بريطانيا الان يبدو وكانها
تحاول استعاده هذا الدور هذا من خلال
التعاون العسكري والتحالفات الامنيه مع
دول هذه المنطقه
بريطانيا هي واحده من الدول التي وصفت
تاريخيا بانها اكثر الدول درايه بهذه
المنطقه تحديدا المنطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا نظرا لتواجدها التاريخي في
هذه المنطقه لكن الدوره البريطاني تراجع
خلال السنوات الماضيه بعد تنامي الدور
الامريكي الان واشنطن يبدو انه لديها
الكثير من الملفات وهناك من يقول بان
واشنطن او الولايات المتحده اصبحت غير
مهتمه بهذه المنطقه على الجانب الاخر هناك
ايضا من يقول بانه المملكه المتحده تسعى
لاحياء تحالفاتها داخل هذه المنطقه حول
هذا الموضوع معنا الفريق جوي مارتن
سامسونج كبير مستشار رئيس اركان الدفاع
البريطاني للشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا او
الان فريق سامسونج او فريق سامي كما تفضل
همم اهلا بك معنا في عسكريا همم واشنطن في
هذه الفتره يبدو انه لديها الكثير من
الملفات وبتت مشغوله اكثر الملف الصيني
والملف الروسي وكثير من الملفات الاخرى
ولم تعد يعني كما يقول بعض بتاعه طولي
منطقه الشرق الاوسط الاهميه الكافيه الان
بريطانيا هل تعود احياء تحالفاتها داخل
هذه المنطقه هل تسعى لاعاده ملئ هذا
الفراغ
ولود سيد همم اود ان اقوله هو ان ان
الخليجي هو امننا وان المملكه المتحده
لعبت على الدوام دورا مهما في المنطقه
ودائما مانولي اهميه لدورنا في المنطقه
وفي الوقت الذي نتحدث فيه الان لدينا
موظفون في مقررات قياده جويه في المنطقه
ومقرات قياده بحريه ولدينا مها مبريه
دائمه فيها ايضا وقد شاركنا في عمليات حلف
الناتو وفي مهام التحالف الدولي لمحاربه
داعش
فان التزامنا لا يزعزع وسيبقى كذلك على
الدوام ولدينا نفس التهديدات والمشاغل
الامنيه المشتركه ونتشاطر فيما بيننا
بتاريخ مشترك فنحن اصدقاء واخوه وزملاء في
المنطقه لعلا ما تغير هو طريقه مزاوله
اعمالنا لكن نوايانا واعمالنا تتسق تماما
مع ما كنا نقوم به منذ عقود من الزمن وسوف
تستمر على هذا المنوال في المستقبل
ومقاربه بناء على ما رايناه يوم هنا وما
يتداوله الناس عن موضوع التغيير فنجد
احيانا ان التعاون في المجال البحري هو
الذي يكون مهيمنا واحيانا في المجال الجوي
او في مكافحه الارهاب او المجالس
السيبراني لكننا سعداء بكل تاكيد بان
المملكه المتحده كانت على الدوام صديقه
لهذه المنطقه وستكون دائما شريكا في
المجال الامني ونشعر بالفخر بالعلاقات
التي تجمعنا
والدور الذي سمح لنا شركاؤنا وحلفاؤنا بان
العبه هنا
روضه
[موسيقى]
فريق سامسونج او فريق سامي التهديدات التي
تواجهها هذه المنطقه هي تهديدات متعدده
وبريطانيا كان لها حضور تاريخ كبير حضور
تاريخي كبير في هذه المنطقه وعلى درايه
بتفاصيل التحالفات حتى الصغيره داخل
المنطقه ما هي ابرز التهديدات التي
تواجهها منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
في هذه المنطقه ااه في هذه المرحله
اف 8
عدد كبير من التحديات والتهديدات التي
تواجه المنطقه هي ذاتها التي تواجهنا بصفه
طيارا ارى ان الامن البحريه يحظى باهميه
كبرى فهو مهم للقطاعات الصناعيه والتجاريه
في المنطقه ولامن الطاقه والامن الغذائي
ايضا كل هذه الاوامر مهمه ودورنا يكمل في
حمايه المجالات الجويه والبحار التي تشكل
مصلحه مشتركه ومكافحه التطرف والارهاب
وانتشار التكنولوجيا التي قد تقعوا بيد
اناس الحلقه الاذى بشعوب المنطقه والشعب
البريطاني وبصوره عامه فهذه مهمه مشتركه
لنا جميعا وثمه تحدي يجب ان نتصدى له معا
ولعل المساله الاخرى هي سلامه الاراضي
ووحداتها في عمليات التهريب وتدفق السلاح
والمواد الاخرى بصوره غير مشروعه ونشر
الافكار في بلادي التي تؤدي الى زحزعه
الاستقرار لكي تثنيه عن الدوري البناء نود
منكم ان تلعبوه في المنطقه مساله مهمه من
ناحيه اخرى ثم تحديات وتهديدات تنبع من
العالم السبرالي والعمليات المتعلقه
بالمعلومات فبعض خصومنا واعدائنا يرغبون
في تحدي الطريقه التي نعيش بها وتحدي
طموحاتنا وتطورنا وقد يستخدمون كل السبل
في المجال السبراني والعمليات المعلوماتيه
من اجل التشهير بنا ومهاجمه مؤسساتنا
واضعافها وهذا مجال اخر منخرط به بشده من
اجل تقديم المساعده في حمايه شعوب المنطقه
والمصالح المشتركه وستشكل تركه للاجيال في
المستقبل
فريق سامي نصف المبيعات العسكريه
البريطانيه تذهب لدول منطقه الشرق الاوسط
لكن هذه الدول تغيرت في هذه المرحله وبتت
تسعى الى توطين الصناعات الدفاعيه
والعسكريه بداخلها الى اي مدى الحكومه
البريطانيه مستعده ان تسمح للشركات
البريطانيه العامله في هذا المجال ان
تشارك دول وشركات هذه المنطقه التكنولوجيا
والافكار خاصه بان هذا يشكل عائق كبير
امام الشركات في هذه المنطقه في هذه
المرحله
نعم هذا رائع فاننا ومن صميم قلوبنا ندعم
طموحات اصدقاءنا في المنطقه والجزء الاكبر
ويتمثل في اعطاء الفرصه لشبابكم من اصحاب
المواهب والمثقفين التوطين هو مبدا سانده
في مجال نقل التكنولوجيا بحيث تتسنى لنا
مساعده اصدقائنا في بناء قدراتهم وهذا
المبدا كان على الدوام من الاولويات التي
نقوم بها منذ فتره طويله وهذا امر لن
يخيفنا خاصه عندما نرى الثمار التي سوف
نحصدها مع اصدقائنا وهذه السمه الرئيسيه
التي نراها هنا في المنفعه المشتركه في
مجال نقل التكنولوجيا وتوطينها وعندما
يتحدث اناس كثر عن نقل التكنولوجيا في
اتجاه واحد في سياق مساعدتنا للشعوب لكي
تبني صناعاتها والتكنولوجيا الخاصه بها
فضلا عن الهيكله الخاصه بها التي تتناسب
مع بلدانهم ومنطقه لابد ان يدركوا ان نقل
هذه التكن سيعود بالخير على المملكه
المتحده فما يجمعنا هو العلاقه المتينه
وثقه التي تجعلنا نستفيد معا من
التكنولوجيا بحيث نستطيع ابتكارها بصوره
مشتركه وليس فقط نقلها بل تطويرها مع
شركائنا بهدف المنفعه المشتركه وهذا
امتداد منطقي لمجابه التحديات وتعزيز
الطموحات وهذا يجب ان يكون هدفنا
فالتكنولوجيا في البحرين التي تم تطويرها
بصوره مشتركه مع المملكه المتحده وتستخدم
فيها لن تقل اهميه عن تلك التي تم تطويرها
في صوره مشتركه في المملكه المتحده ويتم
استخدامها في البحر البحرين
فريق سامي يعني انت كنت احد قاده القوه
الجويه الملكيه البريطانيه ولكن خبره
كبيره في هذا المجال حلقت اكثر من 500
لكن الان الحرف في اوكرانيا هناك الكثير
من الدروس الاستراتيجيه يعني اعلى من
مستوى القوات البريه والقوات الجويه
والقوه الدفاع الجوي لكن بالنسبه للقوات
الجويه ما هو الدرس الاستراتيجي الاهم من
الحرب الدائره ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا
الان الذي تضعونه دائما في حساباتكم كقاده
وتدرسون وحتى في
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لصغار المتدربين او
صغار الطيارين
هناك دروس كثيره يمكننا ان نستقي العبر
منها من الغزو الروسيه الجائر لاوكرانيا
ولعل الدرسه الرئيسيه هو ان الاصدقاء
والشركاء ذوي التفكير المتشابه عليهم ان
يتكاتفوا كحلفاء عند حدوث مثل هذه الاشياء
ولهذا فاننا فخورون بعلاقاتنا وصداقتنا مع
شركائنا في المنطقه لانه في بعض الاحيان
قد يرفض الناس المبادئ التي تجمعنا مثل
مصالحنا القومي المشتركه وقدرتنا على منح
شعوبنا حياه مزدهره مسالمه وحتى انهم قد
يتحدى الدوله
وانه يجب علينا ان نكون اكثر لحمه مع
الحلفاء والاصدقاء الذين يشاطرون نفس
التفكير ويرغبون بالعمل وفقا لم تحكمها
القواعد الدوليه ويتصرفون بطريقه تتسم
بالمسؤوليه في العالم لقد تم بناء تلك
الصداقات والثقه والتحالفات على مر سنوات
طويله ولعل هذا يعزز بشده مدى اهميه
تحالفاتنا في المنطقه ومن منظور القوه
الجويه لابد من السيطره على المجال الجوي
فان فشلت في السيطره على المجال الجوي
سيكون شعبك عرضه للتهديدات وينسحب ذلك الى
قدرتك على ضمان الامن الغذائي وامن الطاقه
وللقوه الجويه دور مهم لتلعبه في تامين
الحياه من الجو ونقطه منطقيه اخيره في هذا
الخصوص هناك خطر داهم في نشر التكنولوجيا
بطريقه تخلو من المسؤوليه كما هو الحاله
بالنسبه للمسيرات وغيرها من الاسلحه
الاخرى لذا لدينا شركات في مجال الامن
البحري وامن الحدود وتعد الشركات الامنيه
تلك مهمه للغايه حتى في مجال المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه بحيث نمنع الذين يرغبون في
الحاق الاذى والضرر ببلداننا وشعوبنا
والبلدان الاخرى ومؤسساتها من فعلتهم لابد
لنا ان نمنعهم من قدره الوصول الينا او
منشن حرب او الحصول على التكنولوجيا ومن
ثم شن حرب علينا لابد لنا ان نتصرف بسرعه
خشيه ان يباغتنا ذلك